la parole est à notre collègue cédric
perrin pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie absents aujourd'hui le chef
de l'etat sera demain à belfort devant
les salariés de general electric pour
annoncer une bonne nouvelle c'est un
projet que les élus du territoire de
belfort ont défendu collectivement
l'ancienne branche énergie alstom
revient sous pavillon français
loin de moi l'idée de jouer les rabat
joie
cette annonce met fin à près de dix ans
de batailles syndicales de tensions
entre salariés et direction d' usine de
reniement de la parole donnée par l'état
et de mensonges des dirigeants de
general electric c'est aujourd'hui une
victoire que l'on doit en partie à la
patience des salariés remercions les
remercions les de s'attarder de ne pas
s'attarder vainement sur le cynisme d'un
président qui a lui-même organisé
lorsqu'il était à votre place en 2014 le
dépeçage de leur usine remercions les de
supporter la politique énergétique sans
vision d'un gouvernement qui agit dans
la précipitation
à quelques semaines des élections
présidentielles remercier d'avoir
attendu la conversion tout aussi récente
que miraculeuse envers le nucléaire du
président après la fermeture de
fessenheim il multiplie les annonces en
la matière et son déplacement à belfort
en est la preuve ce que le président
voit comme une étape de son triomphe
jupitérien est plutôt un nouveau pas
douloureux vers canossa dans sa
politique énergétique a été marqué par
l'inconstance et les renoncements aussi
je n'ai qu'une question avez vous
réellement une stratégie pour la relance
du nucléaire français ou n'est-ce là que
du cynisme électoral une fois de plus
merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge de
l'industrie d'obtenir une hache et merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur perrin non la politique
énergétique que nous menons elle est
fondée sur du professionnalisme de la
rigueur un rapport qui a été notamment
commandé à rte pour justement sur la
base de la précédente programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie tirer les
conséquences de l'accélération de notre
engagement dans la réduction de notre
empreinte carbone sur toutes nos
activités se transporter avec la voiture
électrique et l'hydrogène mât carbone
industrialisés notre pays qui suppose
d'avoir plus d'électricité ce rapport il
a pris deux autres écrit il a associé
4000 experts il a été ouvert en
transparence à l'ensemble des
organisations environnementales donc je
ne crois pas que ce soit un réveil une
semaine avant des échéances électorales
qui nous ont menés pour aller plus loin
ce rapport il est très clair et les
faits sont têtus et barbara pompili
pourra également en attester il y a
trois leviers pour être au rendez-vous
en 2030 et en 2050 de nos engagements
énergétique et avoir une électricité qui
soit bas carbone et compétitive et je
pense que tout le monde remarque
aujourd'hui à quel point c'est important
d'avoir une électricité bas carbone et
compétitive c'est faire le maximum en
matière d'efficacité énergétique et
voilà quatre ans que nous avons investi
massivement au service de l'efficacité
énergétique que ce soit dans les
processus industriels où que ce soit
dans la rénovation thermique et je veux
saluer ici le travail exceptionnel des
manuels bargot et barbara pompili
deuxième élément accélérer le
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
car la politique énergétique n leur sens
elle ne repose pas sur un seul pilier
elle suppose aussi de développer les
énergies renouvelables et là encore nous
avons mis le paquet non seulement en
matière de déploiement mais en matière
industrielle pour avoir des filières
d'équipements industriels des énergies
renouvelables il suffit de prendre
l'exemple de l'éolien marin enfin
construire une nouvelle feuille de route
pour le nucléaire ce qui a été entamée
il y a deux ans je rappelle dans le plan
de relance vous avez 470 millions
d'euros qui sont consacrés au nucléaire
que des f a été confortée dans sa
structure bilancielle pour le nucléaire
et donc nous ne faisons qu'appliquer
cette politique qui est judicieuse pour
notre industrie et pour notre empreinte
carbone monsieur perrin
madame la ministre je vous remercie pour
votre réponse moi j'ai vécu à belfort
les épisodes de rebondissements sur le
terrain avec les salariés avec la
population avec les syndicats d'un
combat difficile pour sauvegarder cet
outil de production cette compétence
développé de longue date qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui la france et à son
indépendance énergétique pour ma part je
n'obtiendrai qu'une seule chose c'est
1300 salariés qui ont perdu leurs
emplois à belfort des compétences que
nous avons perdu en masse parce que nous
avons tergiversé pendant trop longtemps
alors évidemment il y avait là un gâchis
monumental mais ce que je regrette le
plus c'est que vous voudriez nous faire
croire à un cadeau alors qu'en fait il
s'agit d'un cynisme monumental merci